attention all students and staff at this
time we are conducting the internal
lockdown
this is not a drill please initiate
lockdown at this time hello and welcome
to all daint a creepypasta my name is cz
and I started this series one a year ago
when I brought you those first three
Halloween horror stories this time I'm
back with a scary clown creepypasta so
whatever you're doing this Halloween
turn the story on in the background for
some extra chills let's dig right in as
a kid I never really understood why some
of my classmates were afraid of clowns
I didn't really find them scary not that
I found them funny either most of them
just looked kind of goofy and dumb I
remember having this exact argument with
my best friend Kevin at the lunch tables
in elementary his argument was always
that I needed to see the movie it's in
order to understand but being in second
grade at the time my parents would never
let me watch it
I actually remember on Halloween some of
the older kids in the neighborhood
dressed up as clowns and went around
scaring trick-or-treaters maybe I just
had thick skin but I remember one of
them chasing our entire friendly program
and we being left on the sidewalk
laughing at their expense but anyways
this story takes place in November of
that second grade year just after
Halloween we were sitting in math class
boring as ever when situations like this
arise which were quite often during math
Kevin and I would meet in the bathroom
and trade baseball cards we had a system
one of us would give the signal and we
would stagger our bathroom requests as
not to raise suspicion from our teacher
on this particular occasion
Kevin had gone off to the bathroom first
and I gave it a good five minutes before
raising my hand as I was waiting to be
called on our teacher mr. Davis was
interrupted by the sound of the intercom
which was strange because they usually
only did announcements at the beginning
and end of the day
[Music]
attention all students and staff at this
time we are conducting an internal
lockdown this is not a drill please
initiate lockdown at this time our
teacher was pretty calm with his
response walking over to the door and
locking it he told us all the line up
against the back wall and keep quiet as
he crossed the room to pull down the
blinds I figured he had been through
many lockdown drills before and this
probably wasn't anything big we had a
lockdown at my old school once and it
turned out to be a parent who just
forgot to sign in we waited like that
for about five minutes
one kid asked mr. Davis how much longer
it would be and he got a hard from our
teacher signalling that no talking would
be tolerated it was about this time when
I remember that Kevin was still in the
bathroom I debated in my head on whether
I should bring this to the teachers
attention but it was ultimately too
scared after seeing that other kid gets
scolded for making a peep that might
sound kind of ridiculous given the
circumstances but keep in mind I was
only seven years old at the time and I
was still very intimidated by Authority
we waited in silence for a little while
longer with each minute that passed this
situation got more tense I started to
feel anxiety butterflies in my stomach
that's when there was another
announcement on the intercom
[Music]
[Applause]
this circus music started playing over
the intercom and then after that there
was what sounded like laughter in the
background one of the girls in the class
asked mr. Davis what was going on he
told her to keep quiet but his voice
cracked and he stuttered in saying so
that may have actually been the scariest
part of the whole ordeal for me being a
kid and seeing in adults and on top of
that someone who you're supposed to feel
safe with being visibly shaken like that
it was terrifying I guess I wasn't the
only one who felt that way I could hear
sniffles coming from one of the other
kids like they had been crying abruptly
the music just stopped we were all
sitting on the floor in a line in the
corner of the room I actually closed my
eyes as if that would somehow help me
but nothing could block out the
breathing that I heard blaring over the
school intercom until it stopped we sat
in silence for a while longer hearts
racing minds racing faster the silence
was broken by a slant for a group of
screams the sound traveled from down the
hall at this I opened my eyes to see mr.
Davis jump up and push the big wooden
teacher's desk from across the room
I noticed tears streaming down his
cheeks as he did so I started to feel
sick to my stomach
as the anxiety continued to build
footsteps approached from down the
hallway
they stopped near our door I could see a
shadow on the wall
someone was standing out there I could
tell by the shape that it was the shadow
of a clown after a short pause it seemed
like the shadow had disappeared and I
started to feel a little bit of relief
that the clown had walked away there was
a bang on the door and suddenly standing
at the door window was a terrifying
looking clown with bright white face
paint
a huge cartoony toothy smile painted on
his face to contrast the cold evil
looking smirk on his actual lips he was
somewhat overweight and were a big baggy
clown suit the whole class screamed as
he was heatedly tried to open the door
we went from trying to wiggle the
doorknob free to hurrying back and
trying to kick in the wooden door the
glass screaming each time he did so it
realistically didn't last too long
before he gave up and moved on but it
felt like forever to me at the time that
was the last we saw of the mysterious
lockdown clown but in all the hysteria
I completely forgot about Kevin the
lockdown lasted for another twenty
minutes or so until each room was
cleared they made the announcement over
the intercom
telling us the lockdown was over and
teachers could resume classes they
didn't actually ever say what happened
probably not wanting to raise any panic
a few minutes later Kevin appeared at
the door and looked like an absolute
wreck his hair was literally standing up
on end he had dark circles around his
eyes and tears streaming down his face
his entire body was shaking I'd never
seen someone looking so disheveled class
was once again interrupted so that our
teacher could escort Kevin to the nurse
he didn't come back to class after that
and his parents ended up holding him out
of school for a full three weeks to
recover he came back just before winter
break I asked him what happened a couple
of times but he always just told me that
he didn't want to talk about it he ended
up coming to school for the rest of
second semester before his family moved
away at the start of
that summer he was just never quite the
same after that we never got an official
story on what had happened only a swirl
of rumors that the intruder had never
actually been found I shuddered to think
about what would have happened if mr.
Davis hadn't pushed the desk up along
the door anyways
I remembered about this story all these
years later because I often times cut
through his part on the way home from
the bus station
they had a carnival going on over the
weekend it was closed now but it was
about 2:00 a.m. as I cut through the
fairground one of the ticket booths had
a light that had been left on the only
light and the entirety of the area for
that matter and that's when I saw the
clown crash up against the glass and
stare at me with those wide eyes it may
have been just some teenagers or
youtubers pulling a prank but I ran as
fast as I could and didn't stop until I
was locked inside of my room because
clowns terrify me now thanks for
listening to all daint a creepypasta
your total for this episode comes out to
$27 but if you like this video right now
I'll waive that fee and give you
everything you just listened to
absolutely free the creepy clown music
was done by the talented Robert Austin
and the outro music you're listening to
right now was performed by neo yasaka
matzoh i hope you enjoyed the october
upload marathon and what little time you
have left this halloween remember to
subscribe to seize these worlds for new
Horrors every week ring that death bell
for notifications and I'll see you in
the next one assuming we both survive
you